[Music]
cell-cycle
is one of the most breathtaking
processes that helps the cell to not
only grow but also divide we know that a
cell cycle has two major phases one
helps in the preparation of the cell for
the division can you name the
preparatory phase of the cell cycle
that's a right answer it's called the
interphase and moving to the other phase
it carries out the sijin of the cell and
what does that phase called correct
it's the M phase where M stands for
either mitosis or meiosis and how does
the cell decide whether to undergo
mitosis or meiosis well that depends on
various factors and the type of cell
undergoing division keep your eyes glued
to the video to spot the differences
between mitosis and meiosis let me help
you with the first difference between
the two processes mitosis occurs in
somatic or body cells while meiosis
occurs exclusively in the reproductive
cells that means mitosis occurring
irrespective of whether the individual
is a male or a female gives rise to
somatic cells which are exact copies of
the parent cells on the other hand
meiosis occurs in males and females
giving rise to haploid sperm and egg
cells respectively the process of
meiosis however has different names in
both the sexes yes due to the different
cells produced as an end result meiosis
is also referred to as our Genesis that
is the process of ovum production in
females and spermatogenesis that is the
sperm production process in males
another major difference is that mitosis
is used as a mode of asexual
reproduction in lower organisms while
meiosis helps in forming gametes for
sexual reproduction
now let's move ahead with the next
difference have a look at these images
observing this image we can easily
notice the most basic differences
between the two let's begin noting down
each difference individually the first
on the list is that mitosis has only one
cell division while meiosis involves two
successive cell divisions that simply
means mitosis is a single step division
while meiosis is a two-step division and
this results in meiosis having two
phases namely meiosis one and meiosis
two can you note down the second
difference in the list correct mitosis
produces two daughter cells while
meiosis produces four daughter cells and
is there something remarkable that we
haven't discussed yet that's right now
let's move on to the next major
difference this difference is based on
the chromosomal number of the daughter
cells in mitosis the daughter cells are
diploid with two sets of chromosomes
just like the pair itself while during
meiosis the daughter cells produced are
haploid with only one set of chromosome
these daughter cells are called gametes
have exactly half the number of
chromosomes from the parent cells
the former difference also gives Q about
one more difference between the two what
could that be well the image clearly
depicts that all the four daughter cells
produced by meiosis are genetically
different from each other while the two
daughter cells that are produced by
mitosis are genetically similar to each
other now let's move on to the next
difference but before that can you tell
me how many stages of division does the
mitosis process have correct it has four
stages of division and is it the same
for meiosis as well the answer is it
definite no since meiosis involves two
rounds of division that is meiosis 1 and
meiosis 2
the process has a total of eight stages
of division now moving on to the next
difference this point has been studied
by us in the lower grades as well we
have studied that mitosis occurs in all
organisms except viruses and which
organisms can have meiosis meiosis
occurs only in plants animals and fungi
now let's dive deeper and compare the
stages of mitosis and meiosis to explore
some more differences between them the
first stage of meiosis one that is
prophase one is very long consisting of
five sub stages on the other hand
prophase of mitosis is comparatively
shorter than prophase one crossing over
does not occur in prophase while
definitely occurs in prophase one
independent assortment is technically
absent in the metaphase of mitosis while
it occurs in metaphase one the
separation of chromatids takes place
during anaphase and on the other hand
the separation of homologous chromosomes
takes place during anaphase one and the
separation of sister chromatids during
anaphase two so these were the major
differences between mitosis and meiosis
let's summarize them in a single table
before signing off tell me one thing
have you ever wondered what important
tasks do these two processes perform in
our body well mitosis helps in the
healing and repairing of the cells and
tissues of our body it's also
responsible for the growth and the
development of the body
meiosis however helps exclusively
introducing gametes this ensures genetic
diversity and with this we come to an
end of the concept of cell cycle to
learn some more cool concepts related to
cell processes do you keep surfing on
the waves of cell biology happy learning
[Music]
you